this view is informed by the fact we're
now outside of the country in a
political environment that resembles
ours in so many ways except there's less
free speech
there is
more
police involvement in politics brazil is
what america will be very soon if we
don't slow this down
we're here at the presidential palace
because we told you a minute ago we just
sat down with the president of brazil
president bolsonaro ahead of an election
here that will have an effect on the
entire hemisphere very much including
the united states here's part of our
conversation
the parallels between politics and
brazil and politics in the united states
are striking to an american
you are opposed by a coalition of
billionaires college professors
and cnn
tell us
what the opposition wants what will
brazil look like if your opponent wins
my election itself was almost a miracle
i had nothing going for me i was just an
isolated member of congress i was known
as a lower segment of the national
congress in brazil
i connected my campaign anchored only
with a biblical passage john 8 32 ye
shall know the truth and the truth shall
make you free
the media never gave me any visibility
or space much to the contrary they
attacked me all the time throughout the
campaign
if the left wing does come back to power
in my view they'll never leave power and
this country will follow the same path
as venezuela argentina chile colombia
brazil will become one more wagon on
that train the losers will be the
brazilian population and also the left
wing itself
the left-wing voters will lose as a
result
all of south america will be colored red
if you understand me
and in my view the united states will
become virtually an isolated country in
the world
amazing interview and guess what this
will shock you bolsonaro bears no
resemblance whatsoever to the
descriptions of bolsonaro you have read
in the new york times completely
different person
seen that before
we'll show you the whole thing tomorrow
night 8pm
fox news
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight